hi everyone hope you're all well this is
a video compilation of a few collection
to 2019 beyond the balance seminar
there's a cross training event where we
had several instructors teaching from
variety of martial art backgrounds
there'll be clips for each instructor in
this video and I'll put their details in
the description below thanks again to
all the instructors and participants it
was a great training environment and I
think everyone benefited from it if you
enjoy this video give it a thumbs up and
make sure you share and subscribe also
let me know in the comment section
what's your thoughts on what the covered
and do you think we should run another
one next year
we don't want to be just steady and just
roll but once you finally receive energy
and you can receive energy in a
different ways so let's see understand
sideways and somebody appreciate me here
I don't want to be like wait I'll do
this but instead I went to be able to
receive energy in any way sideways
there's a little gap worries
alright so that's we pointed out you
don't develop roles through seeing one
develop and ability to receive in so
here I'm just
from here
[Music]
so again two and then just get to this
position
[Music]
it's not okay
okay
[Music]
and also a little way through so oh my
okay
[Music]